ich habe heute auch ein thema
mitgebracht was mich bewegt und ich
freue mich die meinungen hier vor meinem
mit diskutant zu hören denn in baden
württemberg würde es wahrscheinlich bald
zweig für kinder und jugendliche geben
bislang ist es ja so dass kinder und
jugendliche ausgenommen sind also kinder
und jugendliche haben 3g wir müssen
tests vorzeigen aber jetzt ist es bald
so dass für kinder und jugendliche unter
17 jahren dann zweig oder sogar zweige
plus gelten könnte das könnte sich
nämlich bis zum 31 januar noch nicht und
dann könnte es sich aber ändern ich habe
ein ganz ganz großes problem damit das
ist zweig für kinder und jugendliche
geben könnte das geht ja dann auch schon
ab 12 und zwar besitzt der sozial- und
kultusministerium haben sich darauf
geeinigt die jugendlichen vom ersten
februar im freizeitbereich genauso zu
behandeln wie erwachsene das geht für
mich nicht was war in wittenberg davor
hat und sie merken schon ich bin ja
eigentlich mal sehr konzentriert wenn
ich dieses statement vorschlag aber
irgendwie weiß ich gar nicht wie ich
damit umgehen soll das also kinder mit
zwölf jahren dann ausgegrenzt werden
sollen in baden württemberg auch im
freizeitbereich ab februar nächsten
jahres wenn sie nicht geimpft sind und
ich höre jetzt auf zureden und eröffne
die runde ich schließe mich deine
meinung direkt an wenn ich darf und
steige ganz harmonisch ein heute weil da
kenne ich keine grauzone also was
erwachsene betrifft das ist die eine
sache wir können für uns selbst
entscheiden wie momentan gibt es noch
keinen impfzwang aber kinder vom
öffentlichen leben auszuschließen und
ihr leben dermaßen einzuschränken
solange wir noch nicht hundertprozentig
wissen was diese impfungen fünf oder
zehn jahren mit unserem körper macht da
da werde ich fuchsteufelswild wie man im
schwabenland sagt wenn ich komme aus
baden württemberg ich wünsche schwierig
zu sagen dass es unethisch nun mal
eigentlich finde ich ist zu verlassen
auf diese altersgruppen er will das
heißt entweder sagt man ist es für alle
leute und ethisch zu sagen ihr seid
ausgeschlossen wenn ihr euch nicht im
knast also ich finde das mit dem kind
ich sie zwar auch die wärterinnen kinder
können die entscheidung nicht selber
treffen das heißt es kann ja auch sein
dass ein zwölfjähriges kind sagt mama
ich will geimpft werden dann sagen die
eltern ein und dann wird das kind
ausgeschlossen und das finde ich daran
so innerhalb tage im all zur ja und es
ist tatsächlich so dass die sehr guter
für sich eigentlich schon immer sein
können und wollen die kriegen halt druck
von außen und dass dieser druck das ist
etwas was wir generell habe ich
diskutieren können aber ich finde für
die kinder ist das würde ich jetzt ich
sehe es nicht als unethisch mann der
impfstoff ist nun mal zugelassen ab dem
alter und deswegen finde ich ist
grundsätzliche frage diskussion die wir
führen müssen für mich ist diese kleine
kinder impfpflicht durch die hintertür
wenn ich ehrlich bin beim wenn kinder
dann in baden württemberg ab februar
nächsten jahres jetzt haben sie gerade
auch die schonfrist ist sie bei 2g noch
nicht mitmachen müssen aber das finde
ich sehr sehr schwierig ich würde gerne
anknüpfen an den punkt an dem sie gerade
ansprache mit ob es generell unethisch
ist auch erwachsene zu einer impfung zu
drängen die einfachen der meinung sind
sie sind noch nicht bereit diesen
schritt zu gehen und im moment
eigentlich man kann ja nicht mal
einkaufen gehen ich habe vor wenigen
tagen weihnachtseinkäufe machen wollen
du musst du überall man wird überall
getestet an jeder tür nicht nur am
eingang d moll sondern tatsächlich in
jedem einzelnen laden muss man das noch
mal zeigen ihn im status ja das finde
ich auch schon ziemlich fortgeschritten
sind höher ist doch der nackte wahnsinn
was jetzt abgeht das ist ja mit der
nackte nackte wahnsinn was hier geht ich
bin geimpft bin der top game stores an
kmu jetzt muss ich weil deutschland habe
ich irgendwie als hoch risikogebiet
eingestuft wenn ich in die schweiz
zurück pflege brauchen einen pcr-test
ich meine sie so unglaublich haben noch
ein raumschiff anzug anziehen wo sind
wir eigentlich gelandet und wir sind
jetzt an einem punkt wo der staat mir
ich bin vierfacher familienvater wo der
staat mir in die familien wenn ich jetzt
in baden württemberg leben hier in die
familie hinein regiert also das ist für
mich ich weiß jetzt welche vermutlich
nie mehr in deutschland einreisen können
und auf lebenslang vor jeder kamera
verbaut werden es ist für mich ein
gesundheits taliban ismus der sich hier
wortlos das ist also eine art von
grenzüberschreitung wo ich sagen muss
das geht zu weit das geht das geht
einfach nicht handelt die schweiz astana
ist das interessant
weil die anderen länder damit viel
rigider verfahren als ihr als als wir ja
ich will nicht sagen dass das richtig
ist aber sehr interessant wäre es wenn
wir uns hier durchsetzen mit unserer
haltung wir werden ja gar nicht weit
kommen das ist ja so und sich das
problem konnte immer wieder beruhigen ja
es gibt immer noch ein land das
irgendwie nordkoreanischer unterwegs ist
bezüglich corona aus wie er aussieht
können wir uns schon zurücklehnen aber
wenn ich so in die diskussionen ein
steiger aus meinem freundes umfeld
familienumfeld
also da hört der spaß auf also wenn man
sagen muss man jetzt nicht hinstellen
haben alle die gleichen
also ich habe kinder und was mich
komplett beunruhigt ist der grund warum
sie geimpft werden wollen denn ich habe
hohen respekt vor jedem der sagt ich
habe angst vor dieser krankheit und
lasse mich impfen ich selber bin
dreifach geimpft und hin noch die vierte
und die fünfte ich hab ja auch immer
dazu sagen dass ja diese meinung
vertreten das ist wirklich ein riesiger
jahr aber es gehört ja auch zu bild dazu
also ich bin ich bin ja kein in step
ticker ich bin ich auch kein pharma
skeptiker ich habe ich weniger reisen
gebe immer in pharma koffer quasi dabei
und ich bin und ich weiß ja auch nicht
was er als barry tablette drin ist also
ich bin da auch ich habe auch ein
grundvertrauen in die wissenschaften
aufgrund vertrauen in die in die in die
forschung aber wenn ich höre die
begründung der meiner kinder warum sie
games werden sollen halten das für
unseriös meine kinder meine kinder sagen
nicht naja meine kinder sind jetzt
zwischen 16 und 19 und die sagen er soll
denken den menschen und die sagen nicht
ich habe angst vor der krankheiten
möchte mich impfen lasse sich sagen ich
möchte in die disco gehen oder ich
möchte ich möchte auf reisen gehen und
deswegen dass ich mich impfen das halte
ich für komplett und segel ist und bei
dieser druck da aufgebaut wird ich finde
ein eine eine eine infektion in deinen
körper in kauf zu nehmen damit du in die
disco gehen kannst das finde ich so
unseriös ist kann ich
weiß ich bin über 50 und habe ich bin
ich bin lieber honda oder bobbycar ich
habe angst
aber meine thema immer nmmn die kinder
sind gesund wie man in bayern sagt und
haben und
haben eigentlich gar keinen grund zu
besonderer sorge werden wenn man von
einer gesellschaft tatsächlich aus dem
aus den aus der gesellschaft
ausgeschlossen und dürfen nichts mehr
machen wenn sie sich nicht impfen lass
ich finde das unmöglich mir fehlen da
geworden was ist denn eigentlich die
wissenschaftliche grundlage sagt man uns
auch immer das ist alles wissenschaft
des us wissenschaftlers da habe ich
sowieso nicht dass politik das sind
politische entscheidungen
man muss sich heute schon rechtfertigen
oder wenn man sagt ich lasse mich jetzt
nicht darf geheiß des staates impfen
willst du ja schon fast als aber
gläubiger
voodoo-priester seien
verschwörungstheorien
rechtsextreme und das sind einfach ganz
schlimme mechanismen die der abgehen die
da laufen und noch mal die frage was ist
es die wissenschaftliche grundlage jetzt
habe ich ein jahr lang gehört die kinder
seien nicht die treiber der pandemie sie
sitzt wegen diese mikroben beispiel
meine tochter hat kein corona bekommen
obwohl sie in unserer zwischen
quarantäne die vor einer woche beendet
ist dass ich sollte keine bakterien
schleuder mehr darstellen heute in
unserem bett geschlafen hat die
komplette quarantäne über was in unserem
bett mein mann und ich hatten corona sie
hat es nicht bekommen wir hatten keine
symptome und glücklicherweise sehr gut
aber ein tolles beispiel dass kinder
tatsächlich offensichtlich nicht so
anfällig zu sein scheinen können zum
lassen legen sie nicht nur die atome da
so dass muti gilt es geht wir haben pcr
test gemacht alle wenigen tage damit sie
raus container und wir haben wirklich
zum gleichen glas getrunken die gleiche
gabel benutzt in den tagen nach dem ist
so sagen das ist ganz toll das ist so
bei denen es gibt natürlich auch andere
beispiele hat und es gibt jetzt auch die
neue variante unicom da hat man jetzt
wieder andere sachen zu ich bin keine
wissenschaftlerin dass ich aber gerade
ganz schön finde ich an dem tisch ist
alexander hat beschrieben warum er
geimpft ist dass man seine freie
entscheidung der begründet hat ich habe
mich auch freiwillig dazu entschieden
weil ich einfach mehr der wissenschaft
traue als einem virus den ich nicht
einschätzen kann er wahrscheinlich eine
chinesische labor gezüchtet wurde nur
wahrscheinlich ich sage nicht dass er es
lustig dass ich jetzt hier direkt wieder
als fake news frau werde aber ich finde
diese freie entscheidung die ich auch
ganz bewusst getroffen habe mit der
argumentation übrigens sich natürlich im
impfstoff in deutschland hergestellt
mehr vertraue als irgend einem komischen
virus der sonst wollte mit mir macht das
war meine entscheidung aber zum beispiel
bei meiner schwester dies noch mal sechs
jahre haben wir auch überlegt sich dann
auch impfen lassen entscheiden selber
frei entschieden zwar musste sich dann
auch impfen lassen aber ich finde dieser
druck der jetzt auf kinder gemacht wird
allein schon die überschrift des
artikels die schonfrist für kinder und
jugendliche ist vorbei wir beschreiben
als schonfrist der kinder gar noch kein
zweig haben ja aber das hat wichtige
punkte was machen wir gesellschaftlich
mit dem thema wie gehen wir damit um was
irgendwie für druck auf leute aus und
ich meine wir merken ja was es gerade
macht das macht eine spaltung der
gesellschaft machte spaltung der
familien man fängt an mit seinen kindern
über diese themen zu diskutieren das
eigentlich fürchterlich was sozial für
uns bedeutet und da ist aber ein
wichtiger punkt anzusetzen meine die
frage ist immer wie erstarrt denn hier
ist wer macht das eigentlich muss man
sagen weil es gibt ja nichts neues unter
der sonne das ist der sinn politik ist
eine politische anordnungen und das
fürchterlich ist doch einfach dass das
ganze also eine art
alternativloses eben absolut super
wissenschaftliches programm ausgegeben
wird und immer mehr leute das merke ich
die sind ja auch verzweifelt wie man da
überhaupt noch dagegen sein wenn du
dagegen b ist eben bist du schon einen
ein verschwinden ist das schon ein
rechtsextremer und und das ist wirklich
eine ungesunde sagte ich hoffe dass in
deutschland also dass ich diese neue
regierung jetzt hier nicht einfach
völlig noch evident über übertreibt